hi we want to let you know about this  cool event this saturday we are invited  to a pair ask me anything session with  uh sunyam and  me  and guess whom we'll have as a host it's  dr brian bishoff the head of data  science at weights and biases  and because sanyam runs this chai time  data science podcast awesome by the way  we will have an epic fight between  chai and  coffee and of course we will also talk  about educational content about videos  about the ai and machine learning  communities in general  so  miss coffee bean are we up for it  of course we are but are you  bring your chai or coffee and join us  this saturday at 5 00 pm cet which is 8  am pt find the link and details to the  event in the video description by the  way new ai coffee break video dropping  in hot this week